in your home
[Music]
what's up
would that be all no actually I was
checking out that shirt and I want to
get one for myself do you have one of
those around here
no it's available at crowdershot.com
it's this hateful racist show I watch
so you're racist I watch it ironically
everybody who watches the show is racist
everybody who is on the show is racist
you're racist I'm racist
you don't have that here no at this at
the store no it's racist ironically
store crowdershop.com
pajamas.com
um
[Music]
the iPad
[Applause]
[Music]
yesterday
it was empty
Ahoy everyone and welcome to louder with
Crowder with Dave boom
I want to thank real quick everybody
that came out over the weekend uh to
come out and see Steven's return to
stand up and my uh special yeah as well
some of you were wondering who the
opener was that was Matt McCleary you
can check him out
m-c-c-l-o-w-r-y on social media it was a
really great night and uh hopefully the
special will be out soon yeah so thank
you all for uh your support we really do
appreciate it was a very fun evening was
it like 3 400 people came out to see you
guys yeah it was nuts man crazy it was a
really cool night everybody had fun it
was a good time so thank you all for
your support sorry we weren't on today
uh Steven is out today he's got some
business with the Kraken so I'm going to
fill in and uh also joining me today
Gerald a hey what's going on buddy how
you doing good how about you sir I'm
doing well I think Steven actually what
was it the cat whatever voice he did it
cost him he's actually I think he's got
a little bit of a strep throat right now
is that what it was I think a little bit
yeah he text us more he's like I can
barely talk that would explain the text
communication yeah well okay yeah there
you go I didn't know that was I I always
assume it's cracking business well yeah
I always assuming a lot of times by
someone well somebody somewhere yes of
course so of course we have toga nowon
Ahoy we got Keegan Michael Key bump keep
him the Tool Man good morning one of my
favorite people crawdaddy himself yeah
thank you oh Gerald I don't think you
can get streptococcus from doing
Russians are you sure uh I don't know if
that's how that works I'm not sure I do
hear the number one leading cause of
strep is Impressions it is well yeah
that and Catherine Zeta Jones yeah no
that's true that's just throat cancer oh
another see I was I was really the best
kind of throat cancer a man can get what
a way to go remember this is
he died doing what he loved
well he did what he loved and then he
died two years later live shows a
long-suffering too yes
yeah he died uh of the throat cancer
telling people of the time yeah anyway
so
it's a live show Monday through Thursday
10 a.m Eastern uh Rumble podcast mug
club uh what I mean where you find
podcasts where you find YouTubes do it
and if we're kicked off YouTube Rumble
and if you want to just go to rumble go
to rumble yeah do it I don't mind tell
you where to watch it watch it you watch
it where you want to watch it just just
watch it and why don't you go ahead and
leave a com why don't you let me know
because we unfortunately were not here
yesterday what was your favorite Super
Bowl commercial and don't write all of
them because I know they were all great
but if you get a chance go ahead and
pick your favorite if that's even
possible I'm still laughing do you
remember when they used to be good I do
a long long time ago I remember when you
would go I'm gonna watch this just for
the commercials we used to that's what I
did yeah me too the only time you ever
wanted to actually watch commercials
yeah was this to see what they would be
and now you're like I don't what day is
it
you don't care at all not anymore right
well you guys everybody that had fun in
Dallas we've got some more tour dates
coming up so Stephen and Dave are
actually still hitting the road in
Detroit that 4 P.M show is almost sold
out April 16th make sure you go to
ladder with crowder.com tour and then
Dave you've got some dates coming up uh
as well so we've got you March 25th Ames
theater Burnsville Minnesota yeah that's
right Minnesota Minnesota right I just
need to do it correctly and then April
8th at the Rialto Square Theater in
Joliet Illinois for prisons yes and
April the Tennessee theater in Waukegan
Illinois yes they don't quite talk like
that though but I think those dates are
also on the website as well so uh that's
crickets if you want to laugh if you
want to cry do something else do a
little bit of that we got April dates
right there and yeah come on out Israel
also known for prisons uh Joliet I
thought had uh had the uh not the
theater itself yeah you're performing in
a prison they didn't tell you oh yeah
that's that's why they just gave you
chaps and said here's what you're
wearing that would explain the John
Belushi Juliet Jake of The Blues
Brothers yes yes okay there you go this
is gonna hurt you learned something new
every day
yeah that's gonna be a weird show is
Waukegan near Joliet I mean are these uh
they're kind of far enough apart where
you can play the different ones but I
think I could be completely lying I have
no idea I'm just pretending I know where
I'm going I'm like yeah they're real far
apart they're geography questions it
could be the same theater with different
entrances for all I know
so as we all know it's Black History
Month and right now we have ourselves
some black history facts
[Music]
from Detroit and still can't dance no
and I never understood that font for
Black History Month guys really why not
no no
MTV vax oh okay we got uh let's go ahead
and start the first one crawdaddy what
you got for me I don't know what am I
supposed to be the uh you know the first
one oh last weekend the world's first
black owned autonomous grocery store
which is customers use QR codes to
purchase groceries opened in Atlanta
really wow that's fantastic progress
yeah it scans you while you're carrying
out a sunglasses rack so anyway
shoplifting is no longer free
what you got for me uh this is a sign of
how far black businesses have come since
the oldest one ee Ward moving and
company was founded in 1881 they're
making tons of progress that's great
actually fantastic and however
popular grocery store chain I don't know
if you know this Trader Joe's have you
guys heard of that yeah yeah yes it is
still yet to have its first black
customer oh so there you go yeah and
ladies and gentlemen this is Ben black
history facts
[Music]
some barriers take a while to come down
Dave that's true so they do
I don't even want to go to Trader Joe's
no offense have you seen those prices
they're too good yeah to be true is that
what it is it really is you're like 84
for a banana no that's not Trader Joe's
thing come on Central Market or
something The Cosby Show bags your
groceries that's the same place right
and you got to tip him 20 bucks to carry
it out yeah I think it is that's where
they ashamed that guy they were like why
why are you such a loser because the
man's trying to work oh leave him alone
was it the Cosby yeah they assaulted one
of the guys who was uh working who was
on The Cosby Show oh one of the good
guys well I was about to say was it the
Guys Roofing women or yeah you gotta by
one of the good guys I mean everyone
else who wasn't the star of the show
okay gotcha everyone who was not termed
America's Dad yes correct okay gotcha
the guy who wasn't a monster and proved
a monster and then released from prison
yeah America's rapist just doesn't quite
roll off the tongue as much as easily it
almost immediately released God what a
good world we live in speaking of which
celebrities
speaking of celebrities oh geez yes with
Super Bowl ads remember they used to be
funny we were just discussing the level
yeah they were remember sitting around
with my dad just watching the
commercials and we would howl ah they
were so creative they were just the best
and so expensive that they had to be
creative and funny otherwise you just
blew a million bucks well I think the
air time was obscene even yeah 20 years
ago it was like half a million dollars
for a second oh it was crazy E-Trade had
a monkey just jumping up and down and
they were like this is how we blew a
million dollars you should invest your
money better than we did E-Trade online
that was their commercial was it really
I'm not even kidding this was like 20
years ago that's crazy and a lot of them
wouldn't even be campaigns they just run
them for the Super Bowl yeah that was it
well and well anyway they uh they got
some big names this year regardless of
scripts not that that matters with
anyone in Hollywood because they make
movies regardless of scripts if you
thought um the first one that I saw did
you guys see the one uh with uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger no you get to watch it in
real time with you guys go ahead and
watch
my fellow Gods the Dark Skies have
spoken it is time for Susan I to retire
but where will you go
sorry loose
the BMW IX
BMW the ultimate electric driving
machine
I hate him more it was brutal
that's so terrible the BMW looks awful
it looks like if you've got an offender
Bender they'd be like sorry your Grill's
13 to replace
kind of looks like the sausage car for
The Ambiguously Gay Duo it does doesn't
it it's got a knob it's just what did
they hire the SNL team to write for them
for these commercials well they're
funnier than that oh yeah but if you
thought that was bad here's Miley Cyrus
making her father look talented again ah
you got a voice Molly use it do it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
much younger than her also a fun fact
that was an advertisement for the phone
that uh Miley uses to call people to
tell them that she gave him HPV ah well
lots of calls why it's Miley again my
womb's rot now
you may want to get checked y'all don't
always everything everything hurts
does does it burn you better check for
bumps sir
ah my dad
he used me a lot he's got Nike Breaky
vagina
oh I'd still take a cracking oh all
right look at her you wouldn't no she's
the sexiest Pony I've ever known she
does have a great voice though you gotta
get ready she does honestly yeah she's
just crazy well it's crazy because she
doesn't have a voice she sounds like a
lunch lady speaking voice yeah yeah like
she'll talk and she'll say hey how you
doing and then all of a sudden she'll
sing and you're like wow it's amazing
and the the opposite can be true you
know the smooth voice dialings of one
Gerald Morgan can't sing at all no
terrible he's talking about it I can't
sing No even if you shoot a gun well
that's true
maybe singing's not for you love thanks
appreciate that let's move on I was in a
boys choir when I was young were you
Darren no I've never oh is that what
happened to you
Fair Point
I told you in confidence Dave sorry
about that well on this next one and you
talk about woke everything's got to be
woke now this one's insanely woke and
it's not even funny but they did manage
to get Al Pacino
[Music]
Lubriderm is boring the people who use
it aren't
good right it does remind me I got some
real chapped hands
terrible what was I watching you don't
want to know uh that was a lubridermy
commercial oh it's legit yeah it wasn't
at all from the movie cruising
scene cruising well I know of it it's
basically just he's an undercover cop
right he's an undercover cop in I
believe it's New York if I remember
correctly and it's basically just one
guy's homophobic Terror of in the 80s of
what he thinks gay culture is wow he
says he's like I went undercover to like
study the culture it's like sure you did
wow that's Bruno Kirby from City
Slickers getting uh fisted on the swing
what yeah
yeah he's also in uh what's the DiCaprio
movie Basketball Diaries oh so he's
either a sexual deviant or in City
Slickers both good actor though well I
mean I really believed he was being
okay
squeaky wimpy voice days yeah yeah this
is these completely flipped and the
toned down Michael Corleone actually
knew how to act days before he just
started yelling his lines before he did
uh what was it a Scent of a Woman and
just stayed in character for the rest of
his life killed and justice for all
don't you care yeah don't you even care
I know he's big asses yeah everything I
say is loud why I go big it's better for
my career it's not it's unwatchable he
used to be so good I was watching a clip
of The Godfather the other day with the
mo green scene where he wants to buy the
casino he said come on he's bringing
cocktail weight it's two at a time that
that scene yeah we're not waiters
waitress
you're still on you're Obsession you're
moving yeah
it's not another Lubriderm commercial
the godfinger I uh
yeah it's uh but he's so good in it and
then you have I forget his name John
oh man who plays Fredo so good yeah and
he was only in like five movies and just
every one of them was good before he he
died of lung cancer yeah and it's just
he's such a good actor and now
everything I'll put you know and is just
him screaming yeah
So speaking do what you can speaking of
uh smashing anus smash that like button
go right ahead and uh enjoy the rest of
the show smash it hard see how it's
being fit fine how do you not met how do
you do that and make me not do a fist
joke all right
smash that like button let us know enjoy
the show yeah I don't have any use the
lubricant I go to I go to certain
12-step meetings for that
let's talk about this hey Valentine's
Day did you have a good Valentine's Day
I did yes did you get your sweetheart
something nice I did I gave her some
roses oh yeah and she The Cove had like
not being able to smell thing is going
away just enough to smell the roses
thankfully so oh that's very nice yes
yeah that's good what about you Darren
pretty much the same but I think yours
your bride is blessed that she can't
smell anyway well that's typically a
better yeah well mostly because our son
you know stinks when he poops in his
diaper so but you're you're doing the
dad pull my finger jokes no no no no no
not doing that I'm trying to not let him
laugh too much at you know bathroom
humor but he's a kid he's going to okay
it's just a good way to celebrate
Valentine's can't let him laugh it's
involuntary no no I'm trying not to
encourage it sorry not let him I'm not
like grabbing his mouth and beating him
until he starts crying from laughing
exactly you're not laughing anymore now
are you kid
I set a dirty bomb off at a mosque so
and she was just Valentine's Day well
yeah what
no I uh I did the usual what do you have
the Walking Farts built your dog house
that's what I did
[Laughter]
gave her flowers I found tied to a light
poet in her section
oh
it's all a trap I've I've got a birthday
her birthday's a week after Valentine's
Day I get the double bottom yeah it's
awful oh it's just yeah you have to find
the top one you just described your
wife's birthday is awful no you may want
to walk it back it's a trap it is though
because you have the fake holiday of
Valentine's Day right yeah you know I
mean the real one because we care and
then you gotta get the birthday gift
yeah well it does make like rapid sex I
have Christmas Valentine's Day birthday
in March wedding anniversary in April so
it's really front loaded for us yeah but
then you get a good break the rest of
the year well yeah yeah well then
Mother's Day you got Mother's day as
well so may yeah I mean so I don't know
I don't buy anything oh come on I'm
always like you're not my mom
I don't think that's how it works I do
my dad actually said that's my mom once
and she told me the story it was like
the first year she had twins
and he didn't get it he's like what
you're not my mom
he was just like I didn't nobody told me
the rules she's so romantic it's like my
dad left when I was born I don't really
didn't know that you bought your stuff I
didn't have it modeled for me yeah trust
me from then on it was lots of big gifts
oh man so I don't know what you got your
ex not X
Freudian slip uh yesterday it was
Valentine's Day and the ATF celebrated
by encouraging you to have your exes
swatted oh wow look at that that's the
real thing this is actually a real thing
Valentine's Day can still be fun even if
you break up okay do you have
information about a former partner
involved in a legal gun activity let us
know and we will make sure it's a
Valentine's Day to Remember Call 1-888
ATF tips or email ATF tips at atf.gov
this is real wow now this is fun and all
but I'm sure we can trust the ATF to act
lawfully yes I mean it's it's not like
anything bad has ever happened in
February involving the ATF or anything
now number one what's your emergency
75 minute around our building and
they're shooting at us in Mount Carmel
tell them their children and women in
here and to call it all more than 80
people are believed to have died in
yesterday's fiery conclusion to The
51-day Siege 24 of them children
well shouldn't have broken up with them
there were flowers all right
you know who recently stopped smoking
David koresh Kitty just now boom you
don't remember that one that was the
biggest joke oh I think I remember the
old caress jokes there was a whole
series how do you get that to that point
though where it's like every single
person who decides that they're I don't
know
they become God though later well yeah
later it's first they know God like they
talk to him right right and then
eventually they are him but it always
starts with yeah I got this whole place
it's very peaceful then it turns into I
will take away the burden of having sex
with your wife and the guys yeah yeah
that's that makes sense yeah I guess and
then when they try to leave it's like
why are they shooting at us it's like
right this whole thing was a bad idea so
you mean my kids can't go with me yeah a
guy playing terrible guitar in a bar
told you he was God and you were like
sounds right to me this is sort of on
you I bought God a bud
and they always weave the sexual stuff
into it it's always to their advantage
oh yeah yeah and it doesn't take long I
didn't ask for this yeah it's like day
five
I know you're new here it's like
say oh it's the basis of Scientology
except for some reason they get funding
no offense if you're a Scientologist
lots of ridiculous lots of offense well
Mel Smith the guy straight As in there
wait is he a Scientologist too you
didn't know that no I knew that there
were other crazy totally anthology
I mean straight I mean I thought you
said Scientologist oh are we talking
about the same thing do you know
Scientology is supposedly allegedly a
front for
they can buy into the terrible sci-fi
writings of L Ron Hubbard as a cover for
me yeah excuse me the Bible ah okay
that's what I said good okay it seems
like every high profile person in that
cult has that hanging over them well
that's what it is you're going to expose
you if you ever leave us John Travolta
well who uh I mean according to I don't
know every masseuse and then you have
was this a poll yeah they pull everyone
you have Tom Cruise who does his own
fantastic stunts you know like hanging
onto a plane while a fan blows on them
I could do that stunt that was a real
plan it was a real plane that's true
it's amazing that's an actual plane
tidbit you know and it was a real thing
I mean like it actually took off oh I
wish oh okay yeah oh there is a video of
him harness to it isn't it right yeah
well I could also be harnessed to a
plane it doesn't mean I'd enjoy it right
yeah it's not really like that big of a
deal that's true what would happen
like what's the worst that could happen
I don't know there's some Afghan
refugees that were trying to leave the
country that can tell you they weren't
harnessed well
they gone for dear life I assure you
they weren't hard
I saw the tape if anything they were
nervous and had sweaty Palms So speaking
of Hillary Clinton remember when Trump
warned us about Hillary well early and
often in the day yeah well she's a
beautiful woman with wonderful Maxwell
House ankles
I don't even know what that have you
seen her cankles I have but the Maxwell
oh never mind you can't get it now yeah
it just takes me a minute sometimes to
catch up to understand how her ankles
have swollen diabetes coffee can coffee
can ankles can you imagine those up
around Bill's head
[Laughter]
just weighing them down throwing his
back out his doctor's like I gotta tell
you what you should do find an intern
because you are going to end up with a
severe spinal damage if you continue to
make love to your wife remember when we
well he proved us right again uh a legal
filing from doj prosecutor John Durham
showed Hillary Clinton not only spied on
Trump's campaign
but also his White House office while he
was president look at that well I think
we actually have a clip of Mr President
Trump warning us yes we do yeah we can't
put on things we can't verify Leslie
they spy to my campaign totally verified
no it's been just go down and get the
papers they spied in my campaign they
got the post the times what which one
they went much further than that and
they got caught and you will see that
Leslie and you know that but you just
don't want to know as a matter of fact I
don't know that
now now does she know just go get the
papers which one yeah go look at the
papers no I won't like she just wow
it's like a battered wife like he
doesn't he loves me
no offense to battered that sounds and
chickens all right
we are super excited though about our
next surprise guest guys I was able to
make this happen in an exclusive
interview with the source of this new
Clinton scandal all right are you there
sir yup are you there
hello oh hello sorry there oh no oh boy
hello oh shut it off shut it off
okay all right
um wow they should probably test him for
covet definitely covered all right so
coming up next uh oh boy
uh Saudi authorities have conducted a uh
their biggest Crackdown ever yeah on
Camel BeautyCon contestants I'm sure you
guys know and as we all know there are
camel uh Beauty that's contrast that's
not the Crackdown I was expecting by the
Saudi government no well camels there's
model camels you know that yeah 40
camels were disqualified from the annual
pageant because they had received Botox
to enhance their lips amazing here at
louder with Crowder we're making a
concerted effort to amplify marginalized
voices that's good so we actually have
one of the disqualified camels here to
speak their truth
hmm ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Naomi Campbell
this is terrible
I hate a llamorous ah
[Music]
gorgeous will you be speaking for the
camelster
no um no you're just the ride yeah oh
I'm sorry that's right and I'm so humpy
to be here oh that's a little joke mine
are real though 32 DS and they are
spectacular all right so uh
so you're a professional camel model yes
I am press a lot okay okay uh
interesting but I understand that you
and 40 other camels were recently
disqualified from a beauty pageant for
receiving Botox in your lips those
judges are full of spit
the rest of me is all natural I needed
many years
my job
were you Joe Camel that's racist but yes
they did all die of Home cancer that is
a fact uh I'm just surprised though Joe
Camel was a woman oh used to be a boy I
became a woman three years ago
really
that's that's incredible watch it four
eyes I'm more than just a ride for
Arabian nights I'm naturally who I was
meant to be
so you did you get the whole genitalia
operation you bet your best batch of
branches wanna see my camel toe
too no
ew oh that's this oh you've raised your
foot oh God you got you ah I wasn't
gonna show you my ridiculous B Eve well
I'm
sure it's Dreadful anyway well thank you
for uh coming on the show my pleasure
and
emptiest milk in the world
okay then bye
thank you Naomi Campbell everyone
and has a theme song
well I'm glad we were able to get her on
that's helpful I mean you know sometimes
they prepare for years and years for
that Dave and to have it come down to a
botox injection disqualifications just
heartbreaking for the camera especially
you know it's just nice to know that a
uh somebody who's worked very hard on
becoming who they naturally are yeah is
disqualified for something so simple as
just having luscious lips
camel Beauty yeah well I'm gonna test
those lips out in the parking lot
let's see how Botox they really are see
how these feel real to me I don't think
that's how they do it Dave I'm not sure
they do spit well yes of course but
there's a spitting contest
well it's in the it's in the beauty
pageants right yeah most beauty pageants
have spitting content of course they
would be much more fun if they did does
the botox help or hinder the spitting I
would assume it would hinder I would too
but but then again it could help because
it does make the lips more luscious
because lusciousness is what launches
the spittle yeah I'm gonna let you know
later it's having a gross conversation
we're gonna make a little movie you know
no no no we're not gonna make that movie
watch it's good what nine
oh yeah nine yes
let's talk about this let's lighten the
mood on Friday here we go The Epic Times
I hope I said that right release heavily
redacted body cam footage showing
protester Roseanne Boyland
being beaten while already unconscious
by a black cop
stop
[Applause]
yeah whenever somebody's screaming we
don't need to do this you know you're in
a good situation yeah um the cop uh
little uh or sorry actually this is uh
and again a few of some kids at home
maybe I should have told you earlier to
turn them around uh because they can't
hear you just realized that now uh yeah
that's true uh anyway here's a different
angle uh less redacted uh watch the
right part of the screen
you can kind of tell she's uh geez
whaling yeah oh my gosh
oh man that's sad
yeah I love the caption there by MSNBC
uh new new video released of officers
being dragged into the crowd yeah that's
that's the most um you know impressive
thing that I'm seeing right there is
officers being dragged away I didn't see
that yeah you definitely want to show
something brutal that people should be
aware of and try to just take as much
sting out of it as humanly possible yeah
yeah obviously you don't drag officers
into a crowd but there seems to be a
person being killed also live on camera
there well the good news is the cop uh
Lila Morris was honored at the Super
Bowl last year for defending the capital
wow isn't that great Dan Marino ring for
uh beating someone while they're dead
now it was a terrified cop yeah yeah
terrific a mob has no conscience if
you're in the middle of it you're in big
trouble because it doesn't know doesn't
have any moral compass and someone
that's terrified like that cop like a
woman yeah cop on the front line should
never be is just beating because she has
no sense of what she's doing it's gonna
just be no and it's well in angry mob it
doesn't matter like once you're on and
that's the thing that's it it becomes
just desecrating a body at that point
because nobody stops right because once
you're already dead they're kicking you
while you're down and then they just
keep going and going and going and going
yeah and anybody who has any logic in
the situation like the three people you
hear yelling doesn't matter nobody's
listening no one hears that yeah yeah
there's like the few people that still
have a soul that aren't caught up in
this moment of just completely ruined it
it's just disgraceful like how this is
Allah innocent I don't know if anybody's
been arrested or whatever so it's just
bad this is the second capital fatality
oh sorry I apologize we have to go back
up too uh now it was originally reported
uh that Roseanne Boyland got uh crushed
by the mob yeah I saw that right so
there was one person supposed to be
crushed then it was reported that she
died of a drug overdose that's different
than crushed yeah well I mean clearly
she was oding and having a good time I
think one of the batons was filled with
ecstasy this is the second capital
fatality they've lied about the first
being Brian cignic that is incredible I
you know I don't know that I knew a
whole lot about this I knew that there
was a story about a trump supporter
being killed by being crushed yeah I
read that yeah I read that initially
right but then I didn't know that they
had then said no it was actually the
coroner's report said it was an
amphetamine issue right
um and then now we're looking at it
going are you sure how do you go from
being crushed though to going you know
what we'll just say it was a drug
overdose right I mean she may have had
amphetamines in her system or something
I have no idea I mean the cop no no the
person that the cop was killing and had
to be had other cops apparently put
their arm on her say no no stop stop
stop stop like this person's down the
cop was on the infection done yeah that
is incredible it's amazing yeah well at
least we're not being lied to well
Justice will will likely be done right
there'll be an investigation there'll be
massive outcry about this and they'll
probably be a Wendy's or two that's
burned down not by people you know that
should be burning down a Wendy's but you
know they'll do it no people are going
to take a stand right and everybody who
did this will be held responsible right
I think we all know how the justices
okay we can all rest easy then yeah yeah
who uh who shot the woman in uh on
January 6th I think we know the person's
name now what's your Justice what prison
is he in uh walking the streets wearing
them oh that one the free one yeah still
the prison of Washington DC
that's right that's infuriating who knew
more fun
you said you were going to like this
yeah lighten the mood all right I uh I
you know I'm gonna go on a limb here and
say I didn't write this
I did the camel bid you enjoyed it
started no I had to watch that earlier
and honestly it's so hard for me because
I I just it it hurts to watch and it
sucks it's so sad for these people well
the problem that we have is that police
brutality was this narrative that
everybody cared about obviously right it
was like oh the police are too brutal
they're killing people and they
shouldn't have these kinds of weapons
they shouldn't have this kind of power
and they're still doing it and then we
see situations where somebody is shot
and killed for jumping through a window
right during this time I get it
shouldn't have been there was breaking
the law don't think it was deserving of
the punishment of death also no weapons
were on them no lives were in immediate
danger no no case was brought no
protests had and then we see this and it
the only difference and we've said this
a million times so it just sounds like
the same Bell that we're ringing is that
they had the wrong opinion
it's not equal justice like you should
at least have an investigation into this
that's all I would say you need to do is
investigate these things to give
everybody the details and not just say
yeah clearly drug overdose right there I
know the Baton is beating her in the
head senseless as she's unconscious on
the ground and there's blood everywhere
but it's it's coveted but heroin does
yeah it's omnicron right it's sad
because everything comes down now to
this simple division of a color spectrum
yeah it the whole idea of everything
going on which will even get you into
into our next bit is the whole narrative
right now seems to be you want every
group or every other group whites need
to fear blacks yeah blacks need to fear
whites or at least think that they're
responsible for everything that's
happened to them so that causes you to
hate them because of fear so as long as
they can get you to fear them that will
allow you to get that hate which allows
the country to be divided completely in
half so it'll get you to ignore
like this yeah well it'll get you to
vote for whoever says 100
care of the affected crowd whichever one
that happens to be and the more divisive
and that we can give to the country the
more we can separate us the more power
they have and the more Angry we are and
the more the more we have to put up with
yeah
this is some more fake information we
get I mean it's unbelievable what the
last two years have done to this country
yeah and this is just more of it every
Joe Biden's bringing us back together
though that's true he is at least 39 of
the country thinks he's doing a good job
I'm not sure who they are that's pretty
good numbers that's pretty for the
record we're seeing right now I mean
it's not bad Joe it'll be worse and you
know they're fun to go up foreign
really they were 19. we just we doubled
it and added one it's pretty nice
unapproval rating even your own sides
going like uh is he is he still alive is
he okay guys is this
could somebody just just not
Bernie he awake
all right
uh the the show premiered that we
discussed a little bit last week uh
everything's gonna be all white ah
totally Big Show another show that's not
meant to divide us completely at all uh
last week we covered Showtime's
incredibly racist trailer for their new
show everything it's gonna be all white
like I just said well the first episode
was released on Friday and we watched it
so you don't have to oh thank God yeah
right here are some of the dumbest and
funniest parts of the show number one
the first point they made of course was
about uh as I call it 911 too January
6th we're going to be taking a hard look
at White America
from the perspective of people of color
many different people of color
and there's no better place to begin
than January 6 what 20 21. why is that
but if you're a person of color
you were probably making dinner
washing your car yeah why or doing some
other Regular Show because were you
washing your car in January
every time they're feeling fragile and
these days they're feeling fragile as
wow Nazi Santa well not him again now
wait just a cotton picking minute
let me tell you something
white people can burn down a city after
the Super Bowl and they're called unruly
fans what white people Super Bowls
that's the capital it's called college
football occasionally what if five black
people gather at a barbecue in the park
and the riot police will roll up on
horses like it's the Planet of the Apes
okay none of that made sense no do
horses roll
roll up on horses uh I'm just trying to
finish like this thing out in my head
here so well I don't think horses roll
no they don't if they do their legs are
broken
uh and they're probably not going to get
too very fast that's true uh to ruin
your right yeah
very few times people ride through a
park see a barbecue going and say I
think that's a riot unless the food's
really smelling good and you want it for
yourself
but to say that it's totally fine that
white people get away with rioting uh
let's see let's see a montage of some
riots do you see how the the people of
color now is broadened police and
everybody pull it down
by the way this is all right after the
Super Bowl yeah of course it took over
their vehicles
[Music]
they're they're all barbecues yes
mostly peaceful bar that's a big
barbecue yes torch please
oh that was a good idea yeah widespread
destruction into the early morning hours
it's all so cowardly we never call it
what it is it's so cowardly it was
looting underway nearby
reparation real stand-up guys
[Music]
generally speaking unruly ah just want
to say thank you for the new watch all
right so I'm feeling more empowered by
the minute
foreign
I was saying the people of color tent is
now broadened so we can we can enhance
our numbers aren't we all together no no
you never worked you were slugging that
tribe out all last year with the
knockout punch and now they're all under
the the banner of people of color oh of
course they're they're lying because we
need bigger numbers January 6 was uh not
a bunch of white people marching on
Washington it was people from all Races
that's right all backgrounds well I I
thought I saw some footage of maybe cops
that could have been people of color
waving people towards the capital they
did I don't know videos and then
somebody screaming you're an agent to
the guy yelling come in you're a fan
you're just going off what I saw I mean
granted that could have been a
reenactment I didn't want to get in
trouble that's true you know that's true
it's very and as
can't believe anything anymore nothing
you were probably at home I have to
watch this machine washing your car on
January 20th in your driveway in the
snow doing normal stuff makes perfect
sense what you're doing you were
probably outside shoveling your lawn
like what what are you talking about
do you know
I like how everybody's just doing
something innocent you're doing what you
always do making probably at home
wondering where Dad was yes he was on
his way home Darren
on his way home Papa Was a Rolling Stone
yes the pack of cigs
just starts playing the what is it the
Four Tops that sang that wherever he
laid that was his home and when he died
oh he left was alone
[Music]
not my song no it's a great song Just a
Song I enjoy Black Culture I do too I
don't enjoy the dry I don't do the five
companies that have been dividing this
country for the last two years I don't
know I don't like the city-wide
barbecues now that I know what they are
I just I'm not liking it I don't like
when I go to a barbecue in a park and
like I want to use one of the barbecues
and then there's a bunch of black people
using a barbecue and I'm like why are
they riding
well that's why you call the right the
police you're like hello I'm like hi
there's yeah there's a riot yeah there's
hamburgers and hot dogs over there on
the same Grill yeah I think one of them
has ribs what is this
and I need a grill can you please come
break this I pay my taxes
I'm afraid for my children
they're playing on the same slide ma'am
our horses are rolling right now when we
will be right there pretty soon they're
going to want in the bouncy house
they're going towards the pool no no
it's not complete fans
[Laughter]
more of a wading pool
they complained about the phrase white
lie no seriously oh really what does the
idea little white lie mean I assume that
it means that there are the Nazis in
time by the people who are perhaps
disingenuous and don't necessarily the
truth about something but its view that
guy is a real life Oscar is a grouch
necessarily a social faux pas and that
is not really a bad thing a little white
lie
wow
I don't
believe there's such a thing as a little
white lie
I think a lie is a lie to use the phrase
a little white lie means that if you
tell the white lie it's better than
telling any other kind of lie because
it's a white lie oh boy that little
white lie could very well be
American history I'm kind of
do you like how they started off with
Crystal knock right the night of broken
glass and they're all burning stuff in
the middle in the Nazi Germany scenes
and it's like yeah this is what white
people do they they uh they burn stuff
right right 1940s you had to go back to
the 40s and the late 30s for that isn't
it good that there's not a phrase the
black lie yeah nobody actually uses the
term it's a little while is that a thing
to build a show around yeah oh no yeah
well come on it was a little white lie
well you know pure is the driven snow oh
it's only because it's white if it was
black snow they would never say that no
not at all no it just it doesn't exist
from the sky it covers up everything
yeah
it's a little white lie I I hit him I
look I I hit him with my car and I threw
him in the woods well let's I mean
there's a said it wasn't me a few Little
White Lies out there like mostly
peaceful protests
right right so black people are more
likely to be shot by cops right that's a
little white lie I think right you're
eight inches soft but that's
I am
I think that would be a little black
life that's true if that phrase existed
no that's that's me doesn't exist 11.
centimeters centimeters you'd be
surprised for my size different system
oh I'll show you in the bathroom with
that camera oh you won't show you some
spit yeah all right moving on
so guys don't tell white lies or any
lies or Asian lies there's none of those
I don't think is there any other term
for lie though lying eyes colored I
don't know no you can't hide your
lionized Geralds that's the only thing I
got behind those glasses I can what
brand of glasses are those I have no
idea you don't no why you can't see the
label well it's white privilege I don't
have to care I just well most the most
expensive ones you have please
I'll take the white pair he bought them
in the 40s yes they're Foster Grants
they're edisons the man the man with all
the patents these are Ben Franklin
Originals yes
I have a key and I have a kite I have a
syphilis wig at home as well yes indeed
my favorite kind of wig keeping the
critters
these
they said white people purposely make
minorities the enemy and a documentary
Making white people the enemy the intent
of distorting history is because if you
keep people
disempowered and not thinking that they
have any self-worth then yeah
the the idea it looks like a cook that
was fired for doing cocaine on the job
too much
propaganda you know it's it's really
just a bunch of White Lies
you're fired why lies I get it you know
he's wearing Crocs
with socks oh yeah
I like to be comfortable it doesn't wash
his hands before coming back to the
grill yeah you know it's not a lot you
have type 2 diabetes
it's terminal nice neckerchief who do
you think you are Paul Lind
and why conservatives have been labeled
as racist well you know uh supremacist
domestic terrorists let me read you this
well it's just it's ridiculous it's
white Supreme
like Evelyn Woods speed reading you just
put your rating rainbow take the racist
words out of the fight that's just so
dumb hooked on fionics worked for me
yeah hooked upon experts for B
and white conservatives have been
labeled as racist white supremacists
domestic terrorists by our own
government how do you think uh the the
people who were involved in in these uh
in the storming of the capital
treated by your justice department
should they be treated as domestic
terrorists yes they should be treated as
their bunch of thugs insurrectionists
white supremacists anti-semites in the
FBI's view
extremist threat comes from racially or
ethnically motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race according
to the intelligence I know you found my
skulls terrorism from white supremacy is
the most lethal threat to the Homeland
today
there's no question that there has been
a history of institutional racism in
this country does the president think
our Founding documents are racist I
would say that I will uh I will leave my
comments to speak for themselves and
certainly I think most people recognize
the history of systemic racism in our
country
I will leave my comments to speak for
themselves
it's the dumbest sentence I've ever
heard yes but you're standing right
there how about you speak for yourself
well your comments are what we would
need to hear so you can't have them
speak for themselves if you would please
give us said comments that would be
great or give us any example any
institutional impediment to your
advancement in this country that they
can no institutionally he doesn't exist
but always be racist there are 14 left
in the country that believe in the
superiority of the white race right but
there's no impediment to your
advancement at all in fact shows like
that are to retain the victim card they
cannot lose the victim card that was
never Martin Luther King's dream now
have you ever read that speech you go
back and you look at it we're there it's
just it everything that fizzled out he'd
be like this is not what I meant
guys guys it seems to be totally screwed
this up excuse me sir it's ma'am what is
happening what the hell please but
Sharpton interpreted that is don't lose
that card it's the most valuable one in
the deck it will get you advancement
like you there will be no impediment
with that card well that and that's what
it's meant to do it's meant this show is
meant to keep hate in the hearts other
than plenty of people that's all it's
meant to do yeah there's nothing more
what is it called again it uh all white
everything's gonna be all white
everything's going to be out by the way
is a Chris Rock bid thank you
I swear to God everything's going to be
all white the title stolen yes oh my
gosh who knew these people right when I
heard the title I was like you know it's
a Chris Rock but you just stole your
title the creators are not on the up and
up a 20 year old Chris Rockville were
like duh nobody will know there's no
evidence
why people yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah
and Chris Rock's hilarious and the bit's
hilarious come on when they make fun of
white people I love it I think it's
funny I don't I don't take offense to it
because it's done in the context of
Comedy not in the context of eight well
this is definitely and when a guy
switches from a real ebonic angry voice
to his white voice it's hilarious I find
it so funny that's the way they think we
sound oh yeah and it's all right
other stereotypes you know well and they
also claim that Jesus wasn't white which
you know I mean yeah white folks lies
about history go back centuries they do
few more powerful than those about Jesus
because you can justify almost anything
if God's on your side what
because he's white who cheers
let's have Tom Green Google Jesus White
um
my bum is on the computer my bum's on
the computer
thank you
thank you Jesus
liberal religious agenda thank you white
jesus I know that you would never let me
down amen
what what
so the guy with the New York accent who
did this no black Jesus no why Jesus
he's got brown eyes what the what's
that hair look at my blue eyes they're
like Jesus's blue eyes oh lord they're
like Frankie's blue eyes this happens
all the time
New York New York
sweat Jesus I hope if you pray to white
jesus that happens to the Cross yeah
white jesus or black Jesus I go for more
of a Dominican Jesus black Jesus man
well that makes sense
Jesus was not white no he wasn't he was
Jewish ah I also don't think he looked
like Ted McGinley
like why
what is the dumbest thing that I have
ever heard because the most important
thing about Jesus was his skin color and
that's why people identified with him
yes he was Olive
unbelievable he was a darker man yes
Jewish uh also uh probably looks more
let's let's go with more of a dust and
Hoffman there you go yeah like really
than anything else yeah it could be a
slightly darker shade than Dustin I'd be
fine with that but oh he probably would
be reasonable yeah he could have been
using the desert a lot he might have
been darker and I don't even have been
Blair have you ever met anyone that
cares no no not at all if everybody's
like ah well you know I was gonna follow
this guy until I found out he was white
and I was like oh well that's the he
read the book then I guess because he
created me to be better than he was
right yeah yeah yeah you don't think
that like God every now and then when he
has to go eye to eye with a racist just
comes out as Morgan Freeman
like just as a joke it's just like so
he's got of humor of course so he's like
so what was it you were saying about me
yeah like come it's it's absurd no he
wasn't white he was Jewish
I believe when that guy was pretty he's
Arabic when that guy was praying to
white jesus the for the first time in
history he had to leave a message for
God yeah also look at your apartment and
the table you have God doesn't like you
not to that house that's how it works
but hey I like it I like how they find
the dopiest white guy to be the example
of all of us oh why Jesus please like
Jesus is on my side because he's white
yes let me find a nice fake Rolex in the
city today all the things that matter to
white people what was the Frank Sinatra
reference blue eyes why because Jesus is
blonde-haired blue eyes apparently
according to this stupidity wasn't
Sinatra Italian well I thought yeah that
was a bit of a
these are the people who didn't make it
on SNL somebody was painting the cross I
would have felt weird doing that really
no there's a black Jesus and black cross
I'm sure they just bought it well oh I
know that I've been to a Dollar Tree
attention somebody
discovering that Jesus wasn't white and
going well that's it I I'm done with
this salvation I don't want anything to
do with it
hey Jesus could come down and it's a
black guy and you're gonna go well I
quit that's right I give up that Eternal
I know eternity in heaven I know I'm
sinful I'll take my chances with the red
fella over here in hell why are you
gonna tell me yeah you just go to hell
and you find out that he's he's even
blacker yeah you're like what well
this whole thing's been
I don't believe in any of this that
doesn't matter it doesn't matter you're
in hell good luck gotta be warm it's
just so stupid he's always yeah he's
always pictured as a dark dude with dark
hair and dark eyes Middle Eastern you
mean yeah well yeah but it's you know
he's a darker middle yeah exactly that's
what a middle I mean it looks like and I
mean I'm not gonna live Ben into a few
churches where he is a little bit more
blonder and a little more yeah it
depends on the painting but any artist
rendering if you make a if you make a
painting of Jesus as a black guy that's
fine too whatever I don't I don't care
either right it's fine but to act like
it's a thing but actually we walk around
going he's white thank God Jesus is wet
time you're in church it's like all
right but artists in that era would have
painted him that way yeah of course
there's nothing wrong with that and look
I don't know if you've ever been to a
Catholic church and listened to the
music but trust me a black guy didn't
write it
foreign
[Music]
not so much gospel
they kindly provided us too with the
definition of white people well there's
one place you can be sure to find the
correct spelling of any word the
dictionary oh sure
here it is
goodbye Tom and good luck with your
report thanks thanks a whole lot
wait why was the kid only looking at
words that start with homo when looking
for the definition
it's a bit weird
you look like a young version of our own
John Goodman yeah it reminded me of that
old video where it's like the homosexual
you must look out for have you ever seen
that one right yes yeah he might try to
give you candy lure him into his van
devius and Wiley yeah if you look him up
in the dictionary he will be under this
section that I cannot say the word of
well that's a scene of uh Malcolm X
where if you look up the
um definition of white and black in the
dictionary the White's like you know the
great light the black outer Darkness you
know yeah then like that's essentially
what they were trying to do but they
were like hey uh we already stole the
title of this how can we not steal
another exact scene from a movie and
they're like oh he found an old thing
where a white kid's looking up white
people it's just it's just stupid you're
trying to you're trying to make
comparisons not you them make
comparisons where they don't exist it's
like oh it's saying white and black have
you ever had to close your eyes because
it's so dark outside
uh no so when you describe white as
being This brilliant like bright it's
because it's actually effing bright yeah
I put on sunglasses we're not making it
up okay guys it doesn't mean better no
it's Superior I don't know
I mean I just had it that's the superior
light than the dark room I just left
yeah come on you know we do to torture
people we put them in like sensory
deprivation where there is no light
because it screws with you so utter
Darkness yeah okay get it turns out even
people of color like light oh my God
it's true especially yeah it's easier to
drive in light I'll give you that but if
it's too light yeah you put on
sunglasses and you look you got to get
those military grade Shades that they uh
are they culturally appropriating our
light I think so yeah but we're taking
the shades yes it's an even swap yeah
that's what blind guys wear
because for some reason they want it
even darker it's
no sense
anyway let's just let's just reflect on
this definition plural white by the way
I just want to say real quick for you
never in my life did I have to look up
white people
all right
I was never like what am I does the
dictionary know oh thank God someone
does oh it says me funken Wagner's will
tell me so yeah let's announce her guy I
was gonna google it but I guess I'll use
this here dictionary exactly oh here we
go it says a a nerdy kid
nipples got it
[Laughter]
so uh yeah let's let's reflect on this
definition the plural Whitey a salting
group of European
diaspora diaspora contrasting with
colored people or persons of color I
don't understand they called me a
cracker in there and they did it in a
nice way Saltine you can call me Cracker
they said it crack ass cracker crackle I
want one rib
they said white people
venerate
they said why people venerate people who
die who did bad things right like George
Washington yeah what are some of the
biggest white lies in American history I
do know for example that one one of the
indigenous Brothers came up here uh from
South America I do a lot of work with
indigenous communities and we were at
Mount Vernon and my wife and I were
trans
about George Washington indigenous there
and at one point the guide said that
George Washington had 300 slaves and so
as we were Translating that this
indigenous brother said he controlled
300 other people
and we said yes and he couldn't wrap his
head around that concept the idea that
he would have enslaved 300 other people
and was using the labor of those people
for his benefit alone in the world view
of this indigenous brother that is
Shameless that is something ridiculous
so these are some of the myths that we
venerate we venerate people who did
things that are ghastly that are
unfathomable to people who haven't grown
up in this sea of isms we should not be
venerating certain people
slavery so long ago get over it already
I went Google the white slavery just now
so what's the myth that he had slaves I
guess I don't I don't understand what
they're trying well I guess there was a
guy who's like he had 300 people he was
in charge of and there was a uh
indigenous fellow who was like I don't
understand I don't have a word for and
he said there were 300 of them and he
was like is that more than eight
[Music]
but they stated that he had them so
where's the myth oh the LIE right yeah
George Washington was a good fellow we
venerate these people who who do very
badly oh so the writing is so bad we
have to reach for them we do yes explain
what they are trying to tell us I think
about ourselves yeah I think this is
honestly what the guy was confused about
and I'm not in any way trying to be a
dick I think he was looking at as a
numbers game why were there 300 versus
one guy
I think that's honestly what he was
confused about and then he spun it into
that I I think what's going you know
because indigenous tribes have never
conquered raped and pillaged and
enslaved competing tribes ever in the
history of the world but apparently he
found one indigenous brother from South
America who was like I just don't know
what it is like I've never heard of
slavery I can't believe it we don't take
advantage there's one guy well what part
of South America I don't know but it is
it's like this point that these these
cultures had no idea that's a white lie
no that's actually just a real lie
you're just lying about what history was
well it's a white lie well of course
they're trying to prove their point you
see that that's an indigenous life yes I
guess we're supposed to have lies that
have you know we kept saying indigenous
brothers so does he have some percentage
of melanin that allows him to say
brother about this indigenous person is
there where's that line drug the guy he
put in this interview no no we couldn't
say brother I think he got a 23 in me
back and it was 0.05 and they were like
you can say it it you're good to go
you're good enough to go it was 0.05
don't know
maybe like it's close enough yeah just
go and say whatever you want
just don't just don't do a hard r
[Laughter]
um
brother brothers yeah of course what did
you think we were saying huh yeah come
on you can say brother but don't you
know you know don't brother it up
that's for white people
only white people can say brother it has
to be very Mormons
I know you listen but yeah say brother
it sounds a little different than
brother well Christian you know Baptists
do it too Baptist welcome to the church
brother welcome to the church brother
how are you how you doing Brothers amen
there you go there's a big black Christ
somebody
don't run out of the church it's just
for an object lesson okay we have two
Jesus let's pray to the one that you
want that one right there is ginger
Jesus
yeah would you prefer uh Black Jesus or
white jesus side it's like smoking or
not whatever you prefer it's like a
wedding just pick a side but we do not
have one in the middle well we do not we
do not think there should be an
agreeable Jesus all right thank you for
coming
ha uh we we do uh but I think we do
honor people that have done bad things
you know since since human beings do bad
things
Steps From The Very spot George Floyd
took his last breath this mural has now
become a place to gather and to mourn
now it's a way to speak when words are
not enough now even with the heat index
reaching close to 110 degrees right now
some set up along the procession route
leading to the cemetery where a
horse-drawn carriage right now is taking
floors white horses white Carriage yeah
that's racist a white statue of George
Floyd have a look the hell is going on
here they have just done an Art Exhibit
where they've replaced Jesus Christ with
George Floyd I think that could just be
muscular baby Jesus
you gotta lift Jack Jesus
Jesus
getting jacked with baby Jesus yeah
stupid
[Laughter]
sweet baby Jesus Sweet Baby Jesus well I
want to thank you all for tuning in
today uh I think we've all learned
something new about ourselves and that's
that white people are terrible
um
camels can talk and uh Gerald uh what
did you learn today I learned that you
know sometimes we venerate people who do
bad things but we don't venerate them
for those bad things we do venerate them
for what they leave behind you know like
George Washington left behind
the United States of America yes the
greatest country that has ever existed
and uh I think maybe George Floyd
probably left behind um
fentanyl something maybe maybe just just
Darren anything you learned today
the left thinks people are basically
good
we think we know we're flawed I mean you
come at the world view from you come
with a world view like that it's going
to divide for sure you're not going to
see the world the same way and I think
if you do a propaganda show on Showtime
about how white people are awful you
should probably have black people in it
yes
you just interviewed a bunch of mostly
white people and white people
and why do all the mixed race why do all
the mixed race people in these things
identify with their black half quarter
whatever they never identify with the
the other side they want to raise them
yeah all right so I uh
it's a joke all right anyway smash that
like button tune in every day it's a
live show Monday through Thursday we
appreciate your support thank you so
much for listening and uh now we're
gonna go to Mud Club so until then piss
off YouTube
thank you